hello and welcome back to GameSpot
presents the mix right here at GDC 2015
Adam Saltzman thank you so much for
coming in my friend creator of counter
bolts I have you responsible for all the
time probably like 12 to 24 hours of
sitting on the toilet topping my phone
over and over again
you've made some fantastic games over
the years and you're here to show off
Overland which is a game that I've been
very interested in but we haven't
actually seen any gameplay out yet so
this is the first time we're going to do
it no one's ever seen any gameplay of it
ever
this is Asik the first time anybody is
going to see it in action so we are very
honored that you've decided to show it
here today yeah it's it should be
interesting
emerged in the last bit of code about 20
minutes ago so everyone's like oh blast
like adding columns it happened early
this year it's all right okay well let's
jump right in yeah so tell us about it
what what is Overland so Overland is
sort of a calling it like a survival
tactics game or a survival tactics
roadtrip thing okay um but you're gonna
start out with a couple of people these
people have a couple of specialties
this guy's kind of a hunter class and
this is sort of a traveler class they
have some properties you get a couple of
action points per character per turn and
you kind of explore these little areas
and your goal is to find a car and get
out of here okay so you can search some
things so we found some fuel for our car
that's really important there's a fuel
can back here in the corner so we're
gonna go try and find one of those so
the action points are presumably because
either there will be some sort of
antagonists or that there's some sort of
other like issue with hunger or time or
something whatever are going to be some
antagonists we're gonna grab a little
bit of fuel just to hedge our bets here
excellent and we're gonna come get over
here to the car sweet looking car pretty
sweet right yeah and we'll just open
this up but that kind of made a racket
okay and something heard us yeah
probably a good time chance to a get a
dodge and they are coming so we're going
to put some gas in the car oh wow okay
and now there are things who knows
monthly alright okay car started that's
good and we are just gonna get out of
here don't don't even care about the
actual road itself and not on this one
that I think that road is just might be
in the wrong place but now we've got a
couple of choices oh wow okay you can go
kind of most of these choices here are
gonna be there's gonna be some trouble
but there's also going to be some more
gas there might be some things we might
be able to use as weapons potentially
ahead you guys about yeah this year I
think we're just gonna skip for now I
don't think we're ready to handle that
okay we have anything but we got we got
a lot of gas in the car right now so
that's good so we can go pretty much as
far as we can it's gonna use up some gas
while we go down the road a fuel
conservation ends up being really really
important we have a long term if you run
out of gas you have to pull over on the
side of the road and it's not where you
want to store ice okay oh we found
another hunter oh how many can you have
in your tea as a as many as fit in the
car are there different cars by any
chance there are some different cars
right now there's just this little guy
and there's a pickup truck on the truck
only carries two people okay so if you
have to leave in the truck you must
leave yeah this is okay this is
fascinating it's kind of like a to do
the really annoying journalists thing of
making it comparing over to other games
it's like a like XCOM meets
FTL meets Kentucky red zero or something
we talked about it in those terms
ourselves so that is not a problem for
me oh I can pick up so some of these
different items have some kind of
different things that you can do so oh
there do you have any way of attacking
those at the moment I do I've got a
couple of options so this person has a
shield which I can use to do some
nonviolent kind of backing them off hmm
the reason they want to do some
nonviolent things sometimes these guys
are both pretty effective combatants the
hunters the hunters kind of the only
class has any kind of natural
inclination to violence on the game
right now oh yeah they're coming for us
again I'm gonna shove that guy away
again so we're gonna smack this guy
because he's over here by the car we're
gonna need to get back to a car to get
out of here in any way mmm
watch when I hit him rice he makes a
racket and now we've got more company
okay so there's no clear the room grab
the loot advance is not a loop that
exists in over yeah so you can't simply
just go in with the mentality of once I
kill everything I can get everything I
want yeah so here's gonna be a little
bit of a tricky maneuver so this person
I'm trying to go over these cars to loot
these cars this thing is in the way what
I can do though is get close and this
shield is going to absorb the first hit
I'm gonna fill up the car here grab this
stick and there's not much else to grab
over there this pipe is a great weapon
it doesn't break down over time but it
makes a loud ringing sound when you hit
things and it attracts extra attention
normally those little guys will only
call for about one backup okay but
because we hit him with a pipe we've got
to a handle and is that all the stuff
that you're going to be like not
obfuscating necessarily but just like
leaving open to interpretation this is
like by playing the game you will sort
of learn the rules oh yeah what we've
got um it's uh it's probably not all
super clear quite yet but there is
there's sort of a speech system that's
just starting to come together where the
character is kind of comment on the
things around them and so right now
there's only a couple hooks for it but
for example sometimes when these guys
get out of the car they'll say a little
something right so they might say oh
that made that pipe made a lot of noise
yeah yeah so we get to have the
characters themselves kind of point out
some of the more day oh I'm so I was
just freaking out for this girl cause I
just thought it's really weird to have
two of them in the car and in two hours
yeah one of them is actually pretty
useful this stick is able to do these
guys do +1 damage so the stick normally
isn't going to be able to kill these
guys in one hit but the hunters are a
little better you'll be able to clear
that out but these big guys always draw
to back up right so we're gonna be
running out of time a lot of placeholder
animation in here this is I know
everybody puts out their game and it's
like 95% done they're like come play our
open alpha like that's not what alpha
means to most people this is this is
what we consider an alpha a lot of
placeholder animation but it's the core
gameplay loop our art director is one
named Heather Penn who is just monstrous
talented considering how early it is it
looks fantastic actually I like how this
takes when they rise they rise quickly
it seems like if because presumably the
more enemies that are there the more
chances you're going to have that you're
gonna have to hit one the more chances
then more of them are like it looks like
it gets real bad real quick yeah it's
all kind of put together to produce what
we would call like a feedback loop the
car is damaged like if this car hits
anything it's gonna blow up and kill
everyone so it's really hard to start we
can run over these little bitty guys
without taking damage though nice which
is convenient oh so we have some good
options here now so we can we're gonna
try and get a better car okay I might go
horribly wrong we have some weapons
which helps but this circles red for a
reason right
well being this car is a problem
eventually if we're lucky we're gonna
reach a roadblock here and we're not
we're gonna have a really hard time
punching through the roadblock with a
clumsy car that's gonna explode so we're
gonna try and do our best this is
fascinating what platforms are gonna
release the Sun because you've had some
success on iPod as well yeah we the
great sort of looks like it lends itself
we've been doing a lot of iOS focus
stuff this user interface has gone
through conservatively like a dozen
major iterations
we've actually implemented about half of
those this is the one that we are the
happiest with so far because this maps
nicely a mouse it maps nicely to mouse
and keyboard is nicely a gamepad and it
works pretty well on the touchscreen
we're definitely coming to desktop first
we are hopefully going to be
simultaneously on tablets but we're
gonna kind of take it as we go there's
only you know there's four or five of us
total so we're gonna definitely gonna do
our best and I think it feels best on a
tablet this feels amazing to just like
cuddle up with and kind of little story
you're gonna have to get rid of one of
your your dudes here presumably if we
want to drive out in the truck the truck
has three HP the car only has two okay
none of us are mechanics otherwise we
can repair the car with how many
different glasses are there then right
now there are six there are six in this
demo there are nine ish overall so far
hopefully with ten or eleven by the time
we ship I think there's a couple of
mechanics that aren't in yet so we've
got a couple of options here I I don't
know if we want to take that truck or
not just feel so bad for your for your
yeah when either one of the dudes are
the lady the travel oh we have a
traveler so traveler saves a gallon of
gas on the map the truck has terrible
fuel efficiency okay you really want to
steal a truck like right before the
roadblock you can but the traveler knows
some shortcuts you save a little gas you
might take a traveler a hunter and try
and get over into that truck we can also
siphon the gas out of this car and carry
it over there Wow you can't leave with
two cars presumably you can't just I
you cannot form a care of him and this
guy is gonna take one for the team I
gotta say with the pipe tire stick guy
I think pipe guy he's just gonna stand
over here and make a racket and while
you siphon the gas out of your car and
then leave yep and then leave him yeah
presumably after making quite a lot of
noise yeah he's gonna say yes oh poor
guy have you thought about you know even
a couple
gasps it's kind of a massive point of
debate shape here's the programmer
co-designer really really really wants
characters to be nameable I really
really don't want characters to be
nameable we're really undecided to have
to play testers are like ah be great if
I can name characters and the other half
like really have no interest in it so I
think we know how to include it in the
game in a way that fits in with the rest
of what we're trying to achieve okay so
I think it's I think it's a battle that
I'm gonna lose time will tell but you
have presumably you've got you know
there are the thematic and things that
you want to accomplish with this as well
yeah there's a bunch of things where
we're trying to keep like you know
surfacing information about the items in
the game or the affordances of enemy
behavior or whatever rather than doing
traditional pop-ups or you know a game
diary Bible thing that comes up there's
some ways that those fit in with the
game of the thing that feels the best
right now is having these characters
kind of vocalize their concerns as
they're walking around let's get even
more the gas out of that car let's have
this guy go make another racket oh great
so because it was the pipe again two of
them yeah sorry it's this guy is gonna
get in the truck and just stay real
quiet is that guys gonna stop chasing
him oh yeah okay this is you can a cure
the river and presumably as well yeah
there's there's a radio that you can
find that you use almost I don't know if
it's funny like science fiction books
probably inspired this game more than
any science fiction movies in particular
but like the thumper from dune where you
have this thing that you can set down
and it just kind of makes a racket it
draws things to it and buys you some
time we've got these little radio things
but you can like kind of fit into the
theme of the world a little bit because
sometimes you'll hear stuff on the radio
too right okay which feels really good
look at this oh this is a mess okay yeah
this person anything is gonna stay here
this is a really long path for that
monster he's probably gonna go after
them so this person even though they've
got action points I think I'm just gonna
there you got it does that mean pipe
guys gonna make it no no but I mean he's
got a fighting chance he's we're leaving
him a car we're leaving him a fight way
to Karen oh god okay yeah we did steal
all the gas out of the car but these
might have Gatley he's got a gas can
there we'll leave that for him yeah
it'll be fine
oh yeah there is one right there yeah so
even then you had to make the decision
to either you know to be greedy and yeah
do we want we could go run these guys
over maybe grab a little gas some let's
see if we can get get out of this
situation yeah oh oh oh they just ate
the car that was faster for them to try
and go through the damaged car than to
walk around oh they're just going
through it now that guy doesn't have a
car anymore
these guys are badasses so this guy
there's another person in the car here
so all of these will turn the king you
never just gonna go yeah take those guys
oh yeah just add insult to injury for
that dude just make as much noise as
possible the way was a hero we couldn't
have done that without him there was no
way to do that without him oh I love
Adam Saltzman thank you so much for
coming in thank you I'm showing is when
when when will it be air will it be
playable people when you thinking of
actually having a like a full release
desktop in the summer okay oh wow you're
actually pretty close by in theory
excellent well best of look at us thank
you very much I'm overloaded here for
the very first time really appreciate it